all right I'm back
I finished my second round maybe 45
minutes ago as a very long game and now
in one more hour I started another game
I'm playing Gauri Shankar and I really
haven't done much preparation so this is
gonna be some quick prep I'm probably
gonna stick with the London but I was
just looking at maybe playing Knight c3
so let me switch to here so I do have
his chest calm account let's type in was
a grandmaster dari does he ever played
against this also I have chess EDC open
and go back here prepare against black
so d4 I have six ok he's never
encountered Knight c3
okay d5 Bishop f4 nine of six okay I
might just stick with normal London but
I do want to look into this Knight c3 d5
Bishop f4 hmm so he plays everything
here there's a little question is do I
want to get a position that we're both
less familiar with cuz like c3 it's
still playable no have stockfish running
I mean I wouldn't be more inclined to go
for this if I knew what he would play
against it so he's played he's six yeah
it's just a bad wound in the nice
misplaced on c3 okay so um I guess I'll
prepare London I was looking at one of
the games that he's playing this Andrew
ting oh I forgot to switch windows there
it doesn't matter I'm not gonna play the
javelin and I'm just gonna play standard
London let me go into chess base so I
have the game here he played one of the
the main lines this trendy line with b6
so let me see if I can find any
last-minute ideas I'll have stock fish
running yeah the whole time what's going
on what's the chest pace doing chat
space is bugging save this
that's okay let's reopen this oops
alright I just want something like
reasonable to play maybe I could play
this line this Knight f3 like Knight gf3
and confuse him
check out about that line it's a lot of
that option we get some structure if he
if he takes on that for okay
I'm gonna go back to his chest back on
games and see if he has any games in
this variation let's go back
so Bishop f4 it's a good t5 White's
played Knight c3 most of the time but
I'll stick with III see six say 92 oh
just calm I'm not logged in me logging
Rosaleen alright of course it doesn't
save and that's very gari black
okay so d4 96 say Bishop f4 so yeah he
very rarely plays King's Indian which is
good III he 692 oops so if he plays c5
immediately there's some important move
orders let's look at c5 immediately
because I'm pretty sure there's a trick
here after this edition of d6 and now I
have Bishop e5 check I trick him into
this knight c6 line usually black wants
to delay knight c6 when I would play
Bishop g3 here
maybe maybe it's not so impressive he
does have like Queen b6 and some lines
hmm thought there is a way to trick
black I assume Bishop g3 yeah I blocked
his castles so maybe I again I I would
go for a knight gf3 alright let's go
back to chest lock-on so Bishop d6 on
okay he's has he has two games in Knight
gf3 both of which white one which is
nice so castling oops oh so a few games
here I guess I have to figure out what
move I would play let's go back to chess
face so we're gonna stick with at least
this move order so Knight gf3 let's make
this a mainline block all these castles
I'm looking here so there's a few
playable moves Bishop d3 most common
approved by stockfish okay Bishop d3 of
this so back to chess calm and now he's
played b6 and c5 so it looks like he's
staying with the same setup and there
there's a very similar line where white
uses a tempo to put the bishop on g3 so
I think what I'll do let me bring in
these games I'm actually going to open
them in new tabs so this is a game now
let's go back to chess space not sure if
this is gonna work let's see now that
did not work so let's put screen this I
just want a new board
so this was his game this is one of the
okay so he's played b6 here the other
game was c5 it will focus on b6 for now
c5 will look at should be six white
spleen Queen e2 here I think it's a
little bit smaller Queen e2 is very
logical okay let's stick with what
happened in his game casting it should
be seven c3 fascinating so white doesn't
use the tempo playing Bishop g3 and
leaves attention and I mean the
structure if Bishop takes off for it
seems very playable let's just imagine
takes takes maybe I can find like one
game okay
no one's strong has played this but
stockfish thinks it's playable c5 g3 you
know the other maybe later f5 yeah I
don't mind that so okay I'm being
somewhat predictable playing the lunging
but if we go into this line I'll
surprise him a little bit by keeping the
bishop on f4 so what happened in this
game there should be seven you I played
a bit differently and then took on d6 so
completely differently
let's look okay let's look at night bt7
here ah queen bee one interesting move
I like queen bee one preventing 94
and this is a novelty to promote this
I'll just have some novelty let's see
Queenie 7 I assume 95 Kweisi to
recommended my soccers now 95 is most
consistent black can't take on e5 let's
look at c5 those those my tanks d7 and
Bishop e5 fascinating yeah all I want is
something simple also Bishop g5 is
interesting Saturn h7 and threatening
Bishop g5 it was very crafty because h6
we take on d7 first and then we double
box pawns so it takes takes takes takes
and Queen d1 okay that's line so it
takes the recommending Bishop takes f6
oh but it takes h7 is a move and we're
not getting trapped takes me yeah this
looks very scary for black g6 just
Bishop takes g6
okay so I think I found some some
interesting line Queen be warned I do
want to look at the other game that he's
playing well he plating in some on
Hamilton all right let's look at this
clothes oh yeah I'm not oh I forgot to
copy it okay so this is his game against
Amon Hamilton so playing in very similar
fashion I'm on side dish of g3 here
I see so it actually just transpose 95
Wow
you look at this line
all right so going back to this position
let's say c5 so if he plays b6 and it's
castling there should be seven Queen
just to review b6 counseling there
should be seven c3 oh that was it
without c5 okay
imagine ideas are are similar wonderful
94 immediately oh then I can probably
just take yeah of course just bad
okay so c5 it's one of the main lines in
96 so the question is can we leave the
bishop on that for castling looks very
playable
but the line that Amon played also looks
kind of fun let's look at this here here
an e4 there should be seven five yes so
this is all standard theory 9h five main
line okay Bishop takes okay computer
this is type of position the computer
will kind of crunch through doesn't like
black initially g6 late she takes you to
King takes T to each six fish before wow
there's some crazy line there let's look
at g6 Queen e2 didn't know Mon have a
game in this yeah here is Hamilton again
scott-young
so C takes d4 yeah this looks actually
really fun I remember actually looking
at this line like very briefly at some
point okay so I have a game plan
I started this recording I wasn't sure
what those are gonna play it but now at
least I have a plan
so let's continue to dig h4
and I can't fully trust the computer
like some medians have played this is
white I would imagine it's difficult to
play like practically so Bishop h6 is
very natural I mean looking at the
computer lines just to get the ideas so
h5 it's most likely coming yeah so let's
look at vision t6 or Bishop h6 seems
like the most likely move h5
do you take seat three most common some
people have played g5 here g5 in Bishop
g7 could g5 briefly look to you on 9 f3
seems more natural castling huh
so it looks like just a kind of weird
position I wouldn't mind this casting
takes takes Bishop d7 Brooke 81 f5 I
like 9 f3 seems like the most flexible
let's imagine me throwing this 37
I mean White has like very good control
over the center is down the pawn but
looks like nice compensation night H -
Wow
H - threatening this f5 takes takes
castling what it's crazy cuz ii v as a
whole
okay
yeah I can't analyze so deep but it
seems fun so I was g5 so just review
yeah this is all kind of what I've seen
before Knight g5 is the first kind of
new move for me takes takes if h6
happens of age of 6 9 f3 okay it looks
Pleasant some nice kind of French
structure see takes t49 txt for takes
takes we need okay looks very very nice
we'll take here and then later we play
f4 so g6 was a move here Queenie - oh we
didn't look at Bishop pure a bishop here
ends in a draw right or no oh this just
looks fun for whites weights running
mate g6 Queen age six and if 86 the ship
Wow Bishop h4 yeah I mean this is just
devastating and Bishop f6 look at this
so nasty I need seven 2496 H for a while
so nice and if it takes we just take
back and remaining okay that's a nice
move
okay so this is most likely at least if
we get into this mainline each for
Bishop h6 h5 this is where things can
kind of start deviating I looked at g5
Bishop g7 and I didn't look at let's
take a look f4 looks kind of natural
yeah let's play off for I mean hold onto
the e pawn take sticks
I mean 97 looks like a natural move
going to have 5 9 of 3 9 to 5
I just Bishop F 2 and G 4 okay this is
weird structure because White's down the
pond that has some attack so again
vision d7
similar to other position but that had
included g5 so Bishop h4 Queen c7 9 of 3
other dark spheres are nice say electric
c8 g 3
I'd use the Queen h2g 395 I'm trying to
figure out like White's long-term idea
in Queen c2 an heir yeah I like leaving
the rook on each one okay so is there
anything else oh do you take c3
immediately
it doesn't score great for whites but
look looks like this transposes Bishop
g7
yeah same sort of position and we see
any differences leave the computer
running for a little bit
rook d1 what are the pawns on attacked
routine one there should be seven nine
f3
yeah
I think at a computer it's slightly
confused here it's like 903 is also kind
of transposing roti one bit abuse I'm
nine of three again I'm looking for
whites kind of long-term setup King f1
also flexible
okay at least I have a plan if we go
into this
so just to recap if we go into this line
I play Bishop g3 and this is a line I
played when I started playing the London
I usually like to have the Bishop on b5
in this position but yeah I mean this is
looking playable and let's look at like
this variation again because this is a
sort of new structure for me
I assume it's okay so it's okay with IQ
p95 and some positional game eventually
have five minutes
this game took on G 4th and Knight also
looks very pleasant yeah slow position
will build up
seems like black was a bit better here
some kind of white one our story game so
I think I've I've covered while I wanted
to cover I guess there's a couple other
things to look at like briefly so Bishop
d6
I'll play Knight f3 okay and then we'll
let's say c5 and then let's say b6 these
move orders can be tricky Queen B one
here
well it takes an e for ya maybe there's
a reason why this isn't like theory
takes an e for it looks really nice C 5
coming
I assume this is a winning somehow we'll
just Bishop takes maybe it's not winning
is there any advantage here take stick
sticks castling castling and then take
on c5 okay well I think I'm gonna end
the recording here I might do a few more
glances at some some lines but okay I
feel better now cuz I started not having
any plan and now at least I have some
idea that's one nice thing about playing
an opening that I'm knowledgeable about
like there's so many ideas I've seen
before so even if he tries to surprise
me I think at least I hope I'll have
some idea what to do all right so I'm
gonna try and do some game analysis
recording tonight so stay tuned for more
videos and we'll see you guys in the
future bye